صباح الخير جميعًا ، أنا ممتن حقًا
للدعوة
والشكر الخاص للأستاذ د.
لميا واتسون لدعوتي لي ، أود أيضًا
أن أشكرك على اختيار
موضوع التحويل ، لقد لعب التحويل بالفعل
دورًا محوريًا في مسيرتي المهنية
كنت موضوعًا
للتحويل وفي لحظات أخرى كنت البادئ
ومهندس التحويل وسرعان ما
سأفعل  أشارككم الأداة ، كيف يمكنني
القول أنه قد يكون هناك انحرافات أخرى في حياتي ،
لكن من الجدير بالذكر
هنا التحويل الذي أعتقد أنه
أكبر تحويل حدث لي
في ذروة مسيرتي الدبلوماسية عندما
كنت سفيراً لأول مرة في جنوب إفريقيا
من مصر إلى جنوب إفريقيا ولقد
قمت حقًا بصياغة نقلة نوعية في
العلاقة بين القوتين القويتين
في إفريقيا وكان لدى مطحنة الشائعات
أنني مرشح لمنصب وزير
الخارجية في الداخل وفي جنوب
إفريقيا تم تزويدي ب  أعلى
وسام وسام الرجاء الصالح
فقط لأجد نفسي خارج
وزارة الخارجية تمامًا تم تعييني
أمينًا عامًا للوطنية.
ncil للأمومة والطفولة
لم أستطع التغلب على دموعي لما يقرب
من عامين ، لكنني أعمل بجد للغاية من
خلال ذلك كان ترقية لكوني
رتبة وزير وتفويض
وزير في ذلك الوقت الآن تم تخفيض رتبتي ولكن في
الحقيقة لم يكن هذا خطي  من
التخصص الذي اعتقدت أنه
يمكنني القيام به ، وأنا أعمل بجد فقط
للحفاظ على تراثي في وزارة
الخارجية تدريجياً وشيئاً فشيئاً ،
اكتشفت أنه يمكنني فعلاً إجراء
تحول وتمكنا من ذلك وأنا سعيد
جدًا لأنه راسخ  الآن بعد أن
حققنا أكثر من مجرد تحويل حقًا
لأن التحويل يمكن أن يكون
للأفضل أو للأسوأ ، فقد حققنا حقًا
قفزة للأمام وكيف حققنا هذه القفزة
إلى الأمام هي الرؤية التي امتلكناها
كفريق وأنا فخور جدًا بأن د.  .
كانت لمياء فريقًا كانت قائدة
الفريق في الوقت الذي أصبحت فيه
وزيرة الأسرة والسكان
وأصبحت الأمينة العامة
للمجلس القومي للطفولة
والأمومة انتقلت من احتكاك الأكتاف
برؤساء الدول والشخصيات إلى
التردد على المواقع الأكثر ضعفًا
في مصر وقد أحببتها
حقًا ويمكننا إجراء التحويل لأن
الناس كانوا شركاء ، وثق
الناس بنا ، وقد شعر الناس
بإخلاصنا وتمكنا من نقل
العادات السيئة التي كانت تمارس
دينياً كتقاليد ليس فقط محظورة ولكن
قمنا بتجريمها وكان عملنا متنوعًا حقًا ،
ولكن نظرًا
لامتلاكنا الرؤية ، كان بإمكاننا تحقيق التزامن ، فقد
كانت لدينا رؤية لدينا استراتيجية
لدينا خطة عمل ، كان لدينا الشراكة المناسبة ،
كانت لدينا الموارد التي
حظينا بشعبية كبيرة مع مجتمع المانحين
و  كنا صريحين للغاية
مع المراقبة والتقييم إذا
حدث خطأ ما ، فسنقول إنه
حدث خطأ ، ولم نتردد  تيت ربما
في الوقت الذي شعرت فيه أنه ليس لدي ما أخسره لقد
فقدت مسيرتي الدبلوماسية
، فدعنا نفعل ما يجب أن نفعله وكان هذا
حقًا روح الفريق
بأكمله وتمكنا من تجريم شيء
مثل تشويه الأعضاء التناسلية الأنثوية
وزواج الأطفال.  المخاض وهذه كانت من
المحرمات ، ربما الآن لا تدرك ذلك
ولكن في ذلك الوقت كان من المحرمات حقًا ، لذا
نصيحتي لك أنه إذا كان لديك
فرصة لإجراء تغيير ، فاجعله ولكن من
المهم جدًا معرفة ما تريد
القيام به  إلى أين تتجه إلى من
ستعمل معك ، يجب أن تعمل في
شراكة مهما كانت عبقريتك
في شراكة تفتح العديد من
الفرص بالطبع يمكن أن يرى البعض بحثي أو
سعي المصري للحصول على المركز الأول في
اليونسكو
كتحويل لا أراه على هذا النحو ، فربما
يكون تحويلًا من حيث المستوى
بدلاً من العمل والتركيز على
مصر أو البلدان الأخرى التي تعمل فيها على
المستوى الدولي ومن مختلف
أن هناك اختلافًا  rence وأيضًا
القضايا التي تعمل عليها قد تختلف ،
لكنني أعتقد أن السعي إلى اليونسكو
كان استكمالًا لمسيرتي المهنية كدبلوماسي
كعامل ميداني وأنا في الحقيقة
ممتن جدًا لأننا تمكنا من إجراء التغيير
بسبب شجاعة  استهدفت
مجموعات الأشخاص الذين كنا نعمل معهم
ممن مارسوا أسوأ أنواع
التعذيب على الفتيات الذين
كانوا يمارسونه دينياً وتمكنا
من إقناعهم بأنه أمر سيئ بالنسبة لها
كيف تمكنا من إقناعهم من خلال
تقديم الحقائق والألم الذي  إنهم
يمرون بالتكلفة التي يمرون
بها والفرص التي
تنتظرهم بالطبع لا يمكنهم فعل ذلك بمفردهم
أو حتى إذا فعلوا ذلك بمفردهم ، فهم بحاجة
إلى دعم من قبل القادة الدينيين من
قبل الإعلاميين من
قبل الحكومة  المجتمع المدني الذي كنا
قادرين حقًا في ذلك الوقت على التماسه
والنجاح فيه ، يجب أن أعترف
أنني تعلمت الكثير من نيلسون مانديلا
عندما ذهبت إلى جنوب إفريقيا كأول
سفير كان  في المرة الأولى التي سمعت فيها
عن دور المجتمع المدني ،
كانت هذه هي المرة الأولى التي أرى فيها
رئيسًا يخصص راتبه للأطفال ، وكان
يعلم أن الاستثمار في الأطفال هو
الاستثمار الأكثر ربحية الذي يمكن لأي شخص القيام به
، كما تعلمت أيضًا من تواضع مانديلا في
ذلك الوقت  كان الجميع يغازل مانديلا
من كلينتون ، كل شخص في
العالم كان يغازل مانديلا ، لكن مانديلا
لم يفقد التركيز أبدًا ، لقد كان يعرف ما
يريد فعله وقال منذ اليوم الأول في
ولايته أنني سأخدم
لفترة واحدة فقط وبعد ذلك أريد
لتخصيص جهدي
للفئات الضعيفة وهذا ما فعله
حتى يوم
وفاته كان مانديلا مصدر إلهام
وأنا حقًا فخور جدًا بأن أكون قادرًا على التعلم
من العديد من المواقف التي وجدت نفسي
في بعضها كان ضد إرادتي ولكن
لاحقًا  لقد أثبتوا أنهم مفيدون جدًا ،
لذا في الختام ، أعلم أنك تشاهد
بعض
الصور مع سياسيين في البداية ، هذا
هو د.  ناصر عندما أتت إلى جنوب
إفريقيا ، هذه هي ويني مانديلا
زوجة نيلسون مانديلا الذي توفي قبل بضعة أسابيع
ولكن في الحقيقة وهذه هي السين إيلام
بيكي زوجة الرئيس أوباما بيكي الذي
خلف مانديلا وفي الجدول الزمني
تولى مبيكي منصبه.
يا من يستطيع أن
يملأ حذاء مانديلا لكن
مبيكي كان قادرًا جدًا وهؤلاء هم دائرتي الانتخابية الجديدة من
الأطفال العاملين
وثلاثة أطفال وفتيات ضحايا
تشويه الأعضاء التناسلية للإناث وهم
حقًا السبب الذي جعلني أتسلق إلى
الساحة الدولية
وأعتبر  خبيرة دولية في
حقوق الإنسان أعتقد أنني يجب أن أغلق
هنا الصور يمكن أن تصمت
سترى هذه الفتاة التي تم
ختانها وهي تروي القصة كيف
عانت وحقا كان
نجاحا كبيرا لتشجيع الناس على الانفصال
المحرمات والتحدث علانية وهؤلاء
هم الأشخاص الشجعان في صعيد مصر الذين
اتخذوا قرار
التحويل وهم أكثر شجاعة منا
لأنهم  يمكننا أن نقول لا دون أي مخاوف ،
لكنهم وقعوا في السابق كان لدينا
10000 شخص ،
وسوف تتحدث قرية بأكملها ضد
تشويه الأعضاء التناسلية للإناث ،
وهكذا تمكنا من الذهاب إلى
البرلمان والسعي إلى تجريم
تشويه الأعضاء التناسلية الأنثوية.  كانوا قادرين على
تجريم الحرمان من
التعليم وأعتقد أن السرطان في هذا
المجتمع هو الحرمان
من التعليم لأنه يؤدي بعد ذلك إلى
زواج الأطفال يؤدي إلى تدني كيف يمكنني أن
أقول تدني جودة رأس المال البشري
هؤلاء فتيات بريئات  نتطلع
إلى حياة أفضل ومن
مسؤولية الدولة ضمان
حقوقهم الإنسانية ومن
مسؤولية الأسرة تكريم
حياتهم ويجب علينا تطبيق القانون
لمعاقبة أي مرتكب
ينتهك حقوق الأطفال أريد
أن  شكراً جزيلاً لكم على
اهتمامكم وأتمنى لكم
حدثاً ناجحاً لهذا اليوم وشكراً
لكم